down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preachings and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most
gracious that's also the ongoing mission
of Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in 1991
irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of
Islam irf also imparts dawa training to
D to aptly convey The Message of
Islam irf has one of the most modern
Studios producing programs presenting
Islam which are beamed regularly on many
International TV channels in over 150
countries Dr Zakir Nik president of irf
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints he dispels the many media
myths and anti-islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-islamic forces Dr Zakir Nik is a
medical doctor he's acclaimed the world
over for his spontaneous and convincing
replies to questions posed by critics
and
Skeptics during the question and answer
sessions after his
talks he is also renowned for his
verbatim quotes with references from
major religious scriptures of the
world Dr zaker and other faculty of the
irf trained many D in effective dawa
techniques
ir's website provides free dawa training
material for you to download and become
an effective dii
yourself Dr zaker nik's talks are
available on audio and video cassettes
CDs and DVDs the world
over irf today is creating a change in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims worldwide
towards a proper understanding and
respect for Islam have a question or
doubt about Islam and its teachings now
you know one of the best Resource
Centers to get convincing answers from
is Islamic Research Foundation 5658
tandel Street North dri Mumbai
400009 India phone 2373
6875 fax 9122 2373 0689 email Islam at
the rate
of.net for more information log on to
our website www .
i.net hire someone
toob glory be to
Allah all praise to Allah
there is no God but
Allah
Allah is great
[Music]
now I call upon Dr William Campbell to
present his response to Dr Zakir nyak
[Applause]
well Dr Nike has brought up some real
problems I don't agree with his answer
about the Quran in terms of the alaka
and muda I still think it's a big
problem but that's his opinion and my
opinion so everybody will have to go
home and think about it themselves
he spoke about he hasn't mention met any
person
that took the poison
test I can't present the person because
he's already gone to be with the Lord
but I have friend Harry
Radcliffe and he lived in a town in the
south of
Morocco and one of his people who he
thought was a
friend invit invited him over for a
lunch for a
dinner and he invited the the the wife
and son
also and so when Harry agreed to go
somebody came and knocked on the door
and said the man's going to poison
you so they went Harry took this very
verse that you've read and he decided
that he should go because he had said he
would so he went he waited hoping to
find a time when when the man brought in
the cuscus he could turn the man would
go out and he could turn the cuscus
around but there was no such
time so he dug in and he
ate his wife was too she wasn't able to
eat very much and they had fed their son
before they
went but Harry
ate and that night Harry got pains in
his tummy and he had some
blood but he lived and so two days later
he went knocked on the door and the man
came and opened the door and his face
went absolutely
white and Harry thanked him for the
meal I thought so I give you this one
example
[Applause]
anyway now you have said
about Jesus was only sent to the Jews go
only go to the to the Jews to and not to
the
Gentiles well in the Quran
itself it talks about
Mary and then she says I don't know any
man and Sora
1921 then it says that Jesus is to be a
sign unto men and a mercy from
us in Matthew
4:9 a lady came and anointed jesus'
feet he said whenever there wherever
this gospel is preached in the whole
world what this woman has done will be
told and in Matthew 28 when Jesus is
about to ascend into heaven he says go
into all the world and preach the
gospel well this is not a
contradiction he did say to his
disciples go only to the Jews because
the Jews were given a certain
chance there's a
story in the Bible shouldn't use a story
word story I suppose but history where
Jesus came to a fig
tree and the Fig Tree had brought no
fruit for 3
years and so then the he said shall I
tear it
down and then Jesus answer was no leave
it one more year and we'll fertilize it
and see if it brings any fruit this was
all a parable about Israel he had
preached to them three years and he
would preach another
half but then there are other Parables
that he told where he said all right
it'll be taken away from you the
blessing and given to the
Gentiles Dr Nike has talked about the
day and the
periods the day in the Bible also can
have the time of a long period doesn't
have to be 24 hours as Dr bukai wanted
to insist in his book and I believe that
it was was long periods of
time and there are some these problems
that he has said and I don't deny them
and I don't have good answers for them
but I will tell about
he spoke about
the the two kinds of salt the Sweet
Water and the
saltwater I don't agree with his
explanation the Coran
says has the God has let free the two
barriers two bodies of flowing water
meeting together between them is a
barrier which they do not
transgress then which of the fair
favorite of your Lord will you
deny the word used here for barrier is
barzak means interval or Gap or break or
bar or obstruction or
ismus the same information is given in
aluron 255
53 it is he who has let free the two
bodies of fling flowing water one
palatable palatable and sweet and the
other salty and bitter and he made
between them a barrier and a partition
that it is forbidden to pass the phrase
a partition that it is forbidden to pass
represents two words from the same root
this is done in Arabic to stress or
accent whatever is being
discussed the word hijer means forbidden
interdicted prohibited all very strong
words then the second word which is the
last participle of the verb has the same
past participle of the verb has the same
meanings therefore very literally one
might translate this as he God made
between them a bar and a forbidden
forbidding Dr bukai discusses this
briefly and then he he says though he
admits at the end well it mixes far out
to
sea a scientist friend commenting on
this said it is simply that the salt and
fresh water are physically
separated the influent from the river
displacing the sea water but there is no
barrier
thermodynamically the mixing is a
spontaneous immediate process process
highly favored by entropy the only
barrier is kinetic it takes a long time
for that much stuff to
mix I myself have have had a tiny
example of this I had a friend in
Tunisia and he used to collect he used
to hunt for for for
octopi so I went there once and I jumped
out of the boat and was swimming around
and it was right at the at the where our
small Creek came in
in and the the top
water was cold and the bottom water was
hot I thought how can this be the top is
cold and the bottom is hot and then I
realized the cold water was coming off
of the of out of the river and the salt
water is heavy so the salt warm water
was on the bottom and The Cold Light
water was at the top so there is but
there is no barrier
Dr uh Nike spoke about
languages and of course I am not able to
answer about the languages in in India
well I couldn't answer about the Indian
language angues in America either so
it's no different between India and
America however the place that he talks
about in the Bible the disciples were
given languages as a miracle but they
were the mar many languages that the
people who were there
knew they weren't we languages that were
unknown if somebody came from Spain an
apostle spoke to that person in his
language from Spain if another person
came from Turkey a different apostle
spoke to the other person in his
language from
Turkey I'm going
to go to something that I prepared to
give and talk about
Witnesses in Deuteronomy God told Moses
the way to know true Prophet was did his
prophecy come
true Elijah is an example Elias in the
Quran and he went to the king and he
told him it's not going to rain till I
say
so and so it was 6 months and no rain a
year and no rain once in Tunisia there
was a whole year with no rain then two
years with no rain and three years and
three and a half years and then Elijah
went to the king and he said we're going
to have a contest and they went up on
Mount Carmel and they had this contest
and the King lost and in the Quran it
says that Elias had a major wonderful
Victory but then Elias fell down on his
knees Elijah and he prayed for rain and
the rain
came well Elijah is the first witness
when he said it's not going to rain till
I say so he was the first witness when
God made the rain come when Elijah fell
down on his knees God himself was the
second
witness another example is Isaiah 7:15
BC the Jews were sent into Exile he
prophesied they'd be sent to Exile and
then Cyrus would bring them back Cyrus
who's Cyrus 250 years later Cyrus a
Persian Pagan King sent the Jews back to
Israel back to Palestine and there's a
Cyrus cylinder in London that talks
about
it so we ask the question did Jesus
fulfill prophecies did Jesus do miracles
did Jesus make
prophecies we're going to make a
mathematical study of prophecies it's
called the theory of
probabilities estimate and will estimate
the possibility that these prophecies
could be f fulfilled by chance an
example of this is supposing Dr Nike has
shirts and he I know he has a red shirt
and I say tomorrow he's going to wear
the red shirt and tomorrow he does and
so then I say I'm a
prophet well my friends are going to say
no no that just happened by
chance well then supposing Dr Samuel NE
and he has two pairs of shoes and a pair
of sandals so then the next day I
prophesy what shirt that Dr Nike is
going to wear and I Pro prophesy that Dr
Samuel non is going to wear his
sandals and Dr zabil Ahmed he has five
hats and I say he's going to wear his
turban well what are the chances that I
could have all of these right by chance
oh it's gone away anyway all right you
multiply 1 over 10 by 1 over5 by 1
over3 and you get one over
150 and that's my chance of getting it
by luck is it possible to have the slide
projector down please I mean the the
uh screen
down while the time is going and we're
going to look at TW 10 prophecies and
then one which we will not count because
it's what we want to prove
the first
one
is a prophesy in Jeremiah prophecy in
Jeremiah 600
BC that the Messiah must be from the
posterity of David the days are coming
declares the Lord when I will raise up
to David A righteous Branch a king who
will reign wisely and do what is just
and right in the land he will be called
the Lord Yahweh our
righteousness and the Fulfillment was in
the sixth month the angel Gabriel was
sent from God to Mary the angel said to
her do not be afraid Mary behold you
will conceive in your womb and bear a
son he will be called Jesus he will be
great and will be called the son of the
most high and the Lord God will give to
him the Throne of his father David and
as his kingdom there will be no end and
the angel said to her the holy spirit
will come upon you and the the power of
the most high will overshadow
you therefore the child to be born will
be called
holy well when David was first he was
just from a small family but after he
became king and his family was known
then everybody would remember if they
were the fifth cousin of the king so I'm
going to assume that one in 200 Jewish
people belong to the family of David
the second prophecy is an everlasting
ruler to be born in
Bethlehem Micah 750 BC but you oh
Bethlehem eph who are little to be among
the clans of Judah from you shall come
forth for me one who is to be ruler in
Israel whose origin is from of old from
ancient
days and the Fulfillment though J Joseph
and Mary lived in Nazareth because of an
order from Caesar Augustus Joseph had to
take Mary to Bethlehem his native
town in the Fulfillment it says and
Joseph also went up From Galilee from
the city of Nazareth to Judea to the
city of David which is called Bethlehem
because he was of the house and lineage
of David and while there she gave birth
to her firstborn son well what's the
chance of being born in
Bethlehem there's about 2 million two
billion people were were born in the
world from Micah until now and 7,000
live in Bethlehem so one man out of
every 280,000
men was born in
Bethlehem the third prophecy a Messenger
will prepare the way for the
Messiah this was done by Malachi in
chapter 31 and 400 BC behold I send my
message to prepare the the way before
me and the Lord whom you seek will
suddenly come to his Temple the
messenger of the Covenant is whom you
Delight in whom you Delight behold he is
coming says the Lord of
hosts the Fulfillment the next day John
John the Baptist yah even Zacharia saw
Jesus coming toward him and said Behold
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world this is he of whom I said
after me comes a man who ranks before
for me for he was before me and to this
the Quran agrees also in the St of the
family of Imran 39
3945 when it says that Yahya is to come
witnessing the truth of a word from God
whose name will be Christ Jesus the son
of Mary well how many leaders had a
forerunner well that's hard to say but I
put down one man in a thousand was a
leader who had a forerunner
the fourth prophecy the Messiah will do
many signs and
miracles in Isaiah 7:50 we read say to
those with fearful Hearts be strong and
do not fear your God will come and he
will save you then will the eyes of the
blind be opened and the ears of the
death be unstopped then will the lame
leap like a deer and the S tongue of the
dumb shout for Joy the Fulfillment the
gospel El States it does the Quran that
Jesus did many miracles the Bible speaks
of only four prophets who did many
miracles Moses Elijah Elisha and Jesus
Jesus is the only one that did all four
types of Miracles mentioned in the
prophecy and he sometimes healed all who
came to him well since many Muslims
believe there were 124,000 prophets we
will use that number and say that Jesus
was the one man in
124,000 the fifth prophet prophecy in
spite of these signs his brothers were
against him in the psalm of David a
th000 BC he says I have come become a
stranger to my brethren an alien to my
mother's
sons and in John he gives the
Fulfillment so his brothers said to him
leave here and go to Judea for even his
brothers did not believe in him our
question might be one ruler and how many
would have find his family against him
well many kings who are overthrown by
their own relatives therefore we will
say one in five or 2 * 10 to the first
Power and the sixth
prophecy it's given by Zechariah in 520
BC Rejoice greatly oh Daughter of Zion
shout oh daughter of Jerusalem behold
your king comes unto you he is just and
having salvation lowely and riding upon
an ass the Fulfillment the next next day
the great crowd took palm branches and
went out to meet him shouting
hosan blessed is he who comes in the
name of the Lord blessed is the king of
Israel and Jesus found a young donkey
and sat upon it well obviously Jesus
chose to sit upon the donkey that's no
Miracle it's nothing unusual but the
crowd was there and the crowd came and
and uh praised him and said blessed is
he who comes in the name of the Lord
well how many rulers
Jerusalem how many rulers enter
Jerusalem on a donkey nowadays he'd come
on a in a
Mercedes but one ruler I said one ruler
in a
100 the seventh prophecy Jesus foretells
the destruction of the temple he himself
give the prophecy so Jesus said this in
sometime in 30 ad and as Jesus was going
out of the temple one of his disciples
said to him teacher behold what
wonderful Stone and what wonderful
buildings and Jesus said to him do you
see these great buildings not one stone
shall be left upon another which will
not be torn
down in the Fulfillment about 40 years
later in 70 AD the Roman general Titus
captured Jerusalem after a long Siege
Titus had intended to spare the temple
but the Jews set it on
fire well for the Jews to revolt and
then be crushed would be common so I
said one chance in five
for the eighth prophecy the Messiah will
be
crucified in Psalms David wrote a th000
BC a band of evil men has cruci has
encircled me they have pierced my hands
and my feet oh Jesus David didn't die
this way he died in his bed his feet
were not hand where his feet and hands
were not pierced Luke gives us the
Fulfillment when they came to the place
called the skull there they crucified
Jesus along with the criminals one on
his right the honor on his left our
question is one man and how many has
been
crucified well I said one man and
10,000 the prophecy nine they will
divide his garments and cast lot for his
robe again this is David speaking they
divided my garments among them and cast
lots for my
clothing well John gives us the
Fulfillment in chapter 19
when the soldiers crucified Jesus they
took his clothes dividing them into four
shares one for each of them with the
undergarment remaining this garment was
seamless woven in one piece from top to
bottom let's not tear it they said let's
decide by lot who'll get it well how
many criminals would have a seamless
garment well you can make your own
decision but I said one in a 100
[Applause]
the 10th
prophecy though innocent he would be
counted with the wicked and with the
rich in his
death Isaiah said in 750 BC he was
assigned a grave with the wicked and
with the rich in his death though he had
done no violence nor was any deceit in
his mouth he was numbered with the
transgressors Matthew gives us the
Fulfillment They Crucified two Robbers
with him as evening approached there
came a rich man from
arthea named Joseph a disciple of Jesus
going to Pilot he asked for jesus' body
Joseph wrapped it in a clean linen cloth
and placed it in his own
tomb well how many executed criminals
were innocent well I said one man in 10
and how many innocent man or how many
criminals were buried with the rich I
say one man in a 100 that gives one in a
thousand
finally the prophecy after dying he will
rise from the
dead in Isaiah again it says for he was
cut off from the land of the living he
died and though the Lord makes his life
a guilt offering he will see his
offspring and prolong his days so there
is a there is a prophecy that he will be
come back to life Luke tells us Jesus
himself stood among them and said to
them peace be with you and
then Paul gives us a summary in 1
Corinthians 15 that Jesus appeared to
Peter and then to the 12 after that he
appeared to more than 500 of the
brothers at the same time most of whom
are still living then to James Jesus
half brother then to all the apostles
well that's not something you can give a
value
to so now we're going to look at the
calculation one man and how many men the
world over will fulf fulfill all 10
prophecies this question can be answered
by multiplying all of our estimates I
don't have time to read them but the
answer is one chance in 2 * 2.78 time 10
the 28th 28 zeros let us simplify and
reduce the number by calling it 1 * 10
28 the best information available
indicates the number of men who ever
live to be about 88 billion we'll call
that 1 time 10 to the 11th by dividing
these two numbers we find that the
chance that any man might have lived
down to the present time and fulfilled
all 10 prophecies by luck is one and 10
to the 17th that's written out this way
with 17 zeros
well let's try and imagine this if you
took the state of Texas and you covered
it with dollar coins one meter deep 3
feet deep silver dollars and then one
coin was marked electrically and then I
say there go walk out into the state of
Texas and pick the right coin that's
your chance of picking the right coin by
chance in other words it's no chance
I'm having trouble just a
minute there are many more prophecies
these all show the prophet David or
Isaiah Isaiah as the first witness God
causing fulfillment is the second
witness and God caused the Disciples of
Jesus to write it down these are all
proofs that the Bible is true and from
Yahweh
Elohim the gospel says that Jesus came
from God and paid the penalty for our
sins this is good news the Quran has
hard news Surah nahal 1661 says if a law
were to punish men for their wrongdoing
he would not leave on earth a single
living
creature the problem is that the Quran
States very clear that even those who
have done their best are given only a
maybe in the Surah of their narration
alasas it says but as for him who shall
repent and believe in do right perhaps
as he may be one of the
successful in the forbidding it says oh
you who believe repent toward Allah with
a sincere repentance it may be that your
Lord will repent from you your evil do
deeds in the Surah of repentance at Toba
it says those only shall Worship in the
mosques of Allah who believe in the law
in the last day and observe proper
worship and give arms and fear none
except the law
and it might be that these are of the
rightly guided in the end it's very
lonely if a person does not believe then
he's sure to go to hell but if he does
Believe on the day of judgment he stands
there all by himself in front of Allah
there is no intercessor our friend and
he can only hope that maybe perhaps he
might be among the Blessed this is hard
news where in his dictionary translates
asan as it might be it could be that
possibly maybe perhaps in the Oxford
dictionary English English Arabic
perhaps is translated as
asaan this may be true but it's hard on
the other hand the gospel has good news
Jesus said I did not come to be served
but to serve to give my life a ransom
for many another verse from Paul the
Apostle says if you confess with your
mouth that Jesus is Lord and believe in
your heart heart that God raised him
from the dead you will be saved straight
out this is wonderful good
news you read with me these fulfilled
prophecies as proofs there were 500
people who saw Christ after he rose from
the dead there are many archaeological
finds confirm the Bible I urge you get a
copy of the Bible of the Gospel read it
you will find good news for your soul
may God bless you all thank you
I now call upon Dr Zakir NY to present
his response to Dr William
[Applause]
Campbell alhamdulillah
respected Dr William
Campbell the other people on the Das my
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you once
again with the Islamic greetings
assalamu alikum
may peace mercy and blessings of
almighty God be on all of you Dr William
Campbell only touched on two out of the
22 points I made only
[Applause]
two the first point he raised was he
thinks that the days mentioned in the
bible he refers to to as long periods I
already gave the reply in my talk that
if you consider the days to be long
period like the Quran you can only solve
two problems the sixth day creation
problem and first day light came and
Third Day Earth but the remaining four
problems yet is there so Dr William
Campbell chose to say days a long period
and out of six he solved two scientific
errors the remaining four of the
creation of the universe he does agree
to it that's good
and he says it's difficult to answer the
second point he touched on was regarding
the scientific test of Mark chapter
number 16 verse number 17 18 and he said
one of his friend by the name of Harry
whatever the name was in Morocco in
Morocco he ate
cuscus the Bible says the King James
version as well at The New International
Version which Dr William Campbell refers
to drink deadly poison not eat drink
[Applause]
yet yet I don't mind even a person eats
deadly poison also no problem but
imagine one man in Morocco I'm told
there are two billion Christians in the
world no one can come forward not one
out of the two billion and I thought Dr
William Campbell was a true Christian
believer and I asked him to pass the
test not his friend who already died
and he said that blood came out of the
mouth Dr William Campbell and even I
know very well being medical doctors
that having poison blood comes out and
we cure many people of poison so what so
great test is that should come forward
and do all these things and yet you
should be able to speak foreign tongues
and William campel
said
that at that time if you read Gospel of
Mark chapter 16 those people there they
spoke the languages people
knew and foreign tongues Dr William Tamp
doesn't know there are Indians out here
surely many know Gujarati marati even I
know suppose if I ask
you if I ask particular language n n
Tamil no reply foreign tongues nut
anyone knows Tamil or malam
yes very good are you a Christian
believer are you I'm asking that person
there you're a Muslim anyway fine this
was supposed to be a test passed by
Christian Believers there are many
people in know foreign languages out
here only thing you had to do was speak
to them like what is your name how are
you for example Arabic which you know
new languages which you didn't know and
you proved my point and yet I have not
come across a single Christian who has
passed the test in front of me not a
single out of the thousands I've met
personally and now it can be thousand
And1 after meeting Dr William Campbell
only touch two
points Dr William Campbell did not reply
to my 20 points and he started speaking
about prophecy what has prophecy to do
with science in the Bible if prophecy is
the
test if prophecy is the test then nost
damis book should be the best book nost
damis book should be the the best book
to be called the word of God it is
not he spoke about theory of probability
for the definition of theory of
probability how you can analyze with the
Quran with scientific facts refer to my
video cassette is the Quran God's
word it's available in the fire I've
proved scientifically how can you use
theory of
probability Dr William Campbell used on
the base of Prophecy if I want I can try
and prove his prophecy wrong I don't to
do it I take it for granted for sake of
argument using the concordist approach
that whatever prophecy he said was right
for sake of argument but even if there's
one unfulfilled prophecy the whole Bible
is disproved with the word of God I can
give you a list of unfulfilled prophecy
for example if you read Genesis chapter
number four verse number 12 it says God
told Cain you will never be able to
settle you will be a Wanderer few words
later on Genesis 4: 17 says Cain built
up a city unfulfilled
prophecy if you read Jeremiah chapter
number 36 ver number 30 it says that
Joakim the father of joachin no one will
be able to sit on his throne the Throne
of David no one be able to sit after
Joakim if you read later on 2 Kings
chapter number 24 verse number 6 it says
that Joakim after he died later on
joachin sat on the throne unfulfilled
prophecy one is sufficient to prove it's
not the word of God I can give plenty if
you read Ezekiel chapter number 26 it
says that nebuchad he will destroy TI we
come to know that Alexander the Great
was the person who destroyed TI
unfulfilled prophecy Isaiah chapter
number 7 verse number 14 says
prophesizing of the coming of a person
who be born to a virgin his name shall
be Emmanuel they say the Christians it
refers to Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
born to a virgin the Hebrew word there
is amla which means not a virgin a young
lady the word for Virgin in Hebrew is
bah which is not there even if you agree
we are using concordes we agree virgin
virgin no problem it says he will be
called Emmanuel nowhere in the Bible is
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him is called
as Emanuel unfulfilled prophecy I can
give several plenty unfulfilled prophecy
one is sufficient to prove the Bible
wrong I've given a few according to your
theory of theory of probability Bible is
not the word of
God Dr William Campbell said that
according to the Quran Elijah won the
battle according to the Bible Elijah
lost the battle whatever it is that
doesn't mean that Bible is correct and
Quran is wrong if the statements differ
in the Bible and the Quran you are
assuming Bible is a word of God if both
are supposed to be analyzed it can be
possible that Quran is right and Bible
is wrong it can be possible Bible is
right and Quran is wrong it can be
possible both are wrong it can be
possible both are right so what we have
to do if you have to analyze which of
the two is wrong you have to get a third
Source from outside which is authentic
just because Bible says Elijah lost and
Quran say Elijah one therefore Quran is
wrong is
illogical and William Campbell besides
replying to the scientific errors I
mentioned I'll just touch on the points
which I could not due to lack of time
there are an additional six or seven
points which he mentioned in his talk
which inshallah I'll give the reply
briefly he spoke that the Quran
says according to me and and he showed
my cassette according to Brother shabir
Ali that the light of the moon is
reflected light and he said it doesn't
mean that I'm quoting again the Quran
mentions in Surah fan 25: 61 that
blessed is he who was placed in the sky
constellation placed there in lamp sun
and moon having borrowed light Arabic
word used for moon isar it's always
described as or meaning reflection of
light reflection of light Arabic word
used for sun is sh it's always described
asah which means a blazing TCH a shining
glory and I can give references Sur
chapter number 71 verse 15 and 16 Sur
unus chapter number 10 verse number 5
and so on and he said that if it means a
reflection of light and he quoted the
Quran Sur chapter number 24 verse number
35 and 36 that Allah subhana wa ta'ala
is is the light of the Heaven and the
Earth read the complete verse and
analyze what does it say it says Allah
is the light
no it says Allah is the light of the
Heaven and the Earth it is a similitude
like a niche and within the niche there
is lamp the lamp word is there so Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has got light of its
own and even reflects light like you see
a hogen lamp you know which I he the
lamp inside is like a s but the
reflector is like Moon it is reflecting
light the lamp the tube the tube is
having a light of its own but the
reflector of the hogen lamp is
reflecting light so both two in one so
Allah subhana tala alhamdulillah besides
having light of its own as the quranic
verse says in the niche there is a
lamp and that lamp light of Allah
subhana tala is its own light and Allah
reflects his own light William Campbell
says that the Quran says that Quran is n
is reflecting light of course the Quran
is reflecting the light and the guidance
of Allah subhana wa tala regarding
Prophet Muhammad saham being s yes he is
the Hadith of the Beloved Prophet is
giving guidance to us so Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam is also n he's
also s
alhamdulillah he has his own knowledge
also alhamdulillah he has the guidance
from Allah subhana tala alhamdulillah
so if you use this word n as reflected
light and M as reflected light yet
alhamdulillah you can prove it
scientifically that the light of the
moon is not its own light but it is the
reflected light the are the points that
William Campbell raised was regarding
Surah chapter number 18 verse number 86
that Z name sees the sun setting in
murky water in turbid water imagine sun
setting in murky water was unscientific
the Arabic word used here is it
is meaning it appeared to Z and Dr
William Campbell knows Arabic so what
that means if you look up the dictionary
also it means it appeared so Allah
subhana wa tala is describing what
appeared to zul if I make a statement
that the student in the class said 2
plus 2 equal to 5 and you say oh Zak
said 2 plus equal 5 I didn't say I'm
telling the student in my class that 2
plus 2
I'm not wrong the student is wrong there
are various ways to try and analyze this
ver one is this way according to
Muhammad that means it appeared to it
appeared to
zul point number
two the Arabic word used is M it can be
used for time as well as place when we
say sunset sunset can be taken for time
if I say the sunsets at 7:00 p.m. I'm
using it for time if I say the sun sets
in the west it means I'm taking it for
place so here if you use the word m for
time so
zul not reached that place of sunset use
it at time he reached at the time of
sunset the problem is solved furthermore
you can solve it in various ways even if
Dr William C says no no the basic
assumption is too much it is not
appeared to it is actually this let's
analyze it further the quranic verses
the sun set in murky water now we know
when we use these words like sunrise and
sunset does the sunrise scientifically
sun does not rise neither does the sun
set we know scientifically the sun does
not set at all it is the rotation of the
earth which gives rise to sunrise and
sunset but yet you read every day in the
papers mentioning sunrise at 6:00 a.m.
sun sets at 7: p.m. oh the newspapers
are wrong unscientific
if I use the word disaster oh there's a
disaster disaster means there's some
Calamity we just taking place literally
disaster means an evil star so when I
say This Disaster everyone knows what I
mean is a Calamity not about the evil
star Dr William cell and I know when a
person who's mad we call him a
lunatic yes or
no at least I do and I believe Dr
William cam also will be doing that we
call a person a lunatic he's mad what is
the meaning of
lunatic it means struck by the
moon but that is how the language has
evolved similarly Sunrise is actually it
is just a usage of word and Allah has
given the guidance for the human beings
also he uses so that we understand so it
is just Sun not that is actually setting
not that sun is actually Rising so this
explanation clearly gives us a clear
picture that the verse of the Quran of
Surah 18 verse number 86 is not in
contradiction with established science
that is a way how people
speak he quoted Surah fan chapter 25
verse 4546 that the Shadow lengthens and
prolongatum
we were taught in elementary school and
he said that also in his talk that it is
due to the rotation of the earth that
the Shadow prolongs and gets small but
what the Quran says the sun is its guide
today even a person who has not gone to
school knows that shadow is due to
sunlight even a lay man who has not gone
to school knows that shadow is due to
sunlight so Quran is perfectly right it
doesn't say the sun moves and the shadow
is caused he's putting his own words in
the
Quran sun is its guide It's
guiding the shadow without sunlight you
cannot have
Shadow yes you can have Shadows of the
light it's a different thing but here is
referring to the shadow which you see
which is moving prolonging and becoming
short William Campbell spoke about
Solomon's
death Surah saah chapter 34
verse number 12 to 14 and said that
imagine a person standing on the stick
and he dies and no one comes to know
Etc there are various ways to explain
Point number one Solomon peace be upon
him you are the prophet of
God and it can be a
miracle when Bible says that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him could give life
to the dead Jesus Christ is born of a
virgin birth which is more difficult to
imagine being born of a virgin birth
giving life to the dead or standing on a
stick for a very long time which is more
difficult so when God can do Miracle
through Jesus Christ peace be upon him
why can't he do a miracle to
solam mus Alam parted the sea he threw a
stick stick became snake Bible says that
Quran says that so when God can do that
why can't God let a man rest for a long
period anyway I'll give him various
different answers nowh does the Quran
say that Alam rested on the stick for a
very long period no does it say it just
says that animal maybe some say ant
maybe other animal of the earth came and
bit maybe possible maybe that
suam was just dead and any animal may
have shook the stick andam may have
fallen down but I assume I use the
conflict approach with the
Quran because irrespective whether use
the conflict approach or the Concord
approach the Ayah I quote in the
beginning of my talk 4:82
says do they not consider the Quran with
care had it been for anyone besides
Allah there would have been many
contradictions irrespective whether you
use the conflict approach or the
concordance approach if you're logical
you will not be able to take out a
single verse of the Quran which is
contradicting neither a single verse
which is against established sence
I agree with Dr William Campbell that
Sanam stayed for a long time the answer
is given the same verse that after suam
fell down the Jin said that if you would
have known that Solomon peace be upon
Him died we wouldn't have toil so hard
indicating that even the jins don't have
gab they don't have knowledge of the
Unseen because the Jin thought
themselves to be very great so Allah is
teaching them that even they don't
have William Campbell touched on the
production of milk in 16: 66 the first
person who told about the circulation of
blood was 600 years after the reation of
the Quran and 400 years after Will made
it come into the Western
world that's 1,000 years after the of
Glorious Quran the food you eat go into
the
intestine and from the intestine the
food constituents reach the various
organs via the bloodstream many a Time
by the portal system of
liver and it even reaches the mamory
gland which is responsible for
production of milk and Quran gives this
information of modern science in a
nutshell in Surah n 16: 66 where it says
that verily in the Catal is a lesson for
you we give you to drink from what is
within the body coming from a
conjunction between the constituent of
the intestine and blood milk which is
pure for you to
have alhamdulillah what we came to know
recently just recently in science means
50 years back 100 years back Quran
mentions this information 1400 years ago
and repeat this message in suron 23:
21 William Campbell raised the point
about animal living in community the
Quran says in suram 6:38 we have created
every animal that lives on the earth and
every bird that flies in the air to live
in communities like you and William
Campbell says that you know the spider
kills the mate and and the father Etc do
we kill and the lion does that an
elephant does that he's talking about
the behavior the Quran is not referring
to behavior if Dr William Campbell
cannot understand the Quran that does
not mean Quran is wrong the Quran says
they live in communities talking about
the animals and the bird live in groups
in societies like the human beings it's
not talking about
behavior and today science tells that
all the animals the birds and the living
creatures of the world they live in
communities like the human being means
they live
together and I didn't have time to touch
on all the points on embryology I've
touched on all of his eight nine topics
which he spoke on embryology I'll go
more in detail
the points he raised in emology besides
the one I clarified in my talk he said
that the stages of development were
mentioned by hypocrates and by
gallin and he showed the various slides
the point to be noted just because
someone says some things which are
matching with the
Quran that doesn't mean that Quran has
been copied from that suppose I make a
statement suppose if I make a statement
which is correct which was said by
somebody else earlier that doesn't mean
I've
copied it may be it may not be to use
the conflict approach with the Quran yes
he copied okay fine but let's analyze
the Quran doesn't take the things which
were wrong from hypocrates if you would
have copied you'd have copied
everything it is logical unless he's a
scientist okay this is correct oh this
is wrong I won't copy that this is
correct I'll copy
that all the the stages of Hypocrites
and gallin is not the same as the Quran
Hypocrites and gallin doesn't speak
about leash like substance they don't
speak about muda at all where do they
speak hypocrit and G at that time they
said that even the women have got seen
who say that even the bible say that if
you read in the Bible it mentions in
Leviticus CH number 12 verse 1 to2 that
women give out
seed so actually Bible is copying from
hypocrates and Bible says in job Bible
says in Job chapter number 10 verse
number n and 10 that we have made the
human being from clay like P do milk and
curdled cheese P do milk and C cheese is
exact plagiarization from
hypocrates why plagiarization because
surely that's not the word of God that
portion is unscientific it was said by
hypocrates and gallin the Greeks that
human beings are created like curdle
cheese and Bible copy that
exactly but Quran alhamdulillah
if you analyze and read the books of
emology even of Dr Keith Moore he said
that hypocrates and the other people
like Gan Etc they did give a lot of
thing to emology initially as well
Aristotle many were right many were
wrong and further he goes to say in the
Middle
Ages or at the time of the Arabs the
Quran speaks about something
additional if it was exactly copied why
would Dr Keith Moore in his book give
due credit to the Quran he even gives
due credit to Aristotle to hypocrates
but mentions there many were wrong that
he doesn't mention with the Quran that
is enough proof that Quran wasn't copied
from the Greek
time regarding light of the moon light
of the moon was copied from Greeks you
will tell me that the world is sperical
was copied from Greeks I know the
Pythagoras the Greeks lived in 6th
Century BC who believe that the Earth
rotated the believed that the sunlight
was
reflected if Prophet Muhammad nah copied
why didn't he copy they believe the sun
was stationary they believe sun was the
center of the universe so why did
Prophet Muhammad copy the correct things
and delete the things which were not
correct this is sufficient proof that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon did not
copy he goes to give a list that from
Greek to Syriac syak to Arabic and big
research one statement of the Quran is
sufficient prove it the Quran says in
Surah anab 29 verse number 48 that thou
was not able to recite any book before
this nor was thou able to transcribe
with the right hand if it was so the
toos of vanity will have surely doubted
the prophet was an um he was an
illiterate this fact of history is
sufficient to prove that he didn't
pleasure I from
anywhere
enough imagine even a scientist who is
very literate cannot do this thing but
Allah in his Divine guidance made the
last prophet as an Umi so that the toos
of vanities like people who write books
against Islam they cannot open their
mouths the prophet
ofi there are various things that I can
continue speaking of the Bible I've
covered up all his arguments against
Quran alhamdulillah not a single point
to prove Quran is against science he has
not touched on 22 points of mine touched
on two not proven so all 22 yet prove
that Bible is incompatible with modern
science Point number 23 in the field of
zoology in the field of zoology it is
mentioned in Leviticus chapter number 11
verse number six that hair is aat we
know that hair doesn't cut previously
people thought by the movement of the
hair now we know hair is not a cutch
neither does it have a compartmentalized
stomach it's mentioned in the Proverbs
chapter number 6 verse number 7 that ant
has got no ruler no Seer no Chief today
we know that ants are sophisticated
insect they have a very good system of
Labor in which they have Chief they have
Foreman they have workers they even have
Queen they even have ruler therefore
Bible is unscientific further more it's
mentioned in the Bible in Genesis 3:14
and Isaiah 65: number 25 that serpents
eat dust no Zoological book says serpent
it does it's mentioned Book of Leviticus
chapter number 11 verse number 20 among
the Abomination things fouls with four
feet they are an Abomination and some
Scholars say that foul is a wrong
translation of the Hebrew word o in King
James it should be insect or Wing
creature and in New International
Version it says Wing creature but it
says all
insects which are four-footed are an
Abomination they are detestable for you
I want to ask Dr William Campbell which
insects have got four feet even a
student who has passed Elementary School
knows that insects have got six feet
there is no bir in the world there's no
foul in the world there's no insect in
the world which are got four feet
furthermore there are mythical animals
and fabulous animals mentioned in the
bible as though they exist for example
Unicorn it's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah 34 Verse number 7 talking about
unicorn as though it exist you look up
in the dictionary it says animal which
has got a H's body and a
horn which is only available in mys
my time is over only I like to tell that
apologize if I've heard the feelings of
any Christians that was not my intention
it was just a reply to Dr William
Campbell's book to prove that Quran is
compatible with science and Bible though
portions we do consider maybe the word
of God complet is not the word of God
it's not in conciliation and I would
like to end my talk with the quotation
of the Glorious Quran from Surah is CH
17 81 which
says when truth is in falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to perish ald